after 35 years on the Henderson Fire
Department Don Griffey is enjoying
retirement running a fire hydrant repair
business but the memories of what
happened three decades ago today at the
pepcon facility in Henderson are still
fresh Don was in one of the first
engines heading to the initial fire at
the plants when the first explosion
happened
it blew and we just reached our hands up
and caught the windshield on the truck
as it blew out
and he stopped immediately and we took
it from the side
and I just turned around and I said you
know what there ain't nothing there
anymore we're turning around getting out
of here
Griffey says they were about a quarter
of a mile away when that blast happened
the second explosion happened as Griffey
was outside of his ladder truck trying
to direct the driver how to turn around
the blast knocking him up onto the top
of the truck the blasts and all killed
two people injured 372 others and
completely obliterated the pepcon
factory along with a marshmallow plant
next door
when you have to see that explosion and
I mean I'm inside that thing
so I'm saying oh my gosh there's there's
got to be people laying all over the
ground and that's really why I was
looking stopping at the vehicles coming
back out all the fire Griffey ended up
heading to the northern command post for
the rest of the day directing Crews
across the city to check on the calls
related to the explosion the blasts
caused property damage over a 10 mile
radius with severe damage surveyed up to
a mile and a half from the explosion
site now the factory was producing
ammonium perchlorate it's a key
component in the rocket fuel used for
NASA's space shuttle program at the time
Griffey insists he and other
firefighters were not aware that the
chemical compound being produced at the
facility was being produced at the
facility or else they would have been
more hesitant to approach the initial
fire I'm Patrick Walker 8 News Now